marcher dans les feuilles mortes en
cette fin d'automne quoi de plus naturel
pourtant nous ne sommes pas en forêt
mais dans un ancien lieu de culte
transformé en jardin d'hiver des arbres
des végétaux une étendue d'eau et
partout des œuvres d'art 50 au total du
minuscule au monumental comme cette
feuille d'érable géante grossi 10 fois
ou bien encore cet
oiseaux ce sont les formes naturelles
des morceaux de de bois donc que j'ai
trouvé sur les plages qui m'inspire
l'animal vous voyez toute cette tête là
en fait c'est c'est c'est la forme
naturelle évidemment il y a tout un
travail de de nettoyage de ponçage de
bouchage aussi pour lui assurer une
certaine
[Musique]
pérénité
quand les œuvres d'art rencontrent le
monde végétal le mariage fonctionne
parfaitement la nature est quelque chose
qui inspire beaucoup les artistes
d'abord il y a de la poésie il y a de la
matière à donner il y a des couleurs il
y a des des tas de choses et selon les
tendances on peut le prendre de façon
humoristique on peut le prendre voyez de
façon totalement
imaginaire on a mis un nain et les
enfants et les adultes bien sûr peuvent
faire voler des flocons de de neige
jusque sur la tête du du nain un jardin
d'hiver qui donne tout à la fois voir
sentir toucher ou même entendre comme
ces papillons en porcelaine de Sèvre qui
s'entrechoqu dans un éternel
recommencement comme le cycle de la
nature